Jason is in Tampa Florida
hey Jason welcome to the dojo how can I
help hey thanks for having me Dave sure
what's up hey quick question I had a two
back surgeries in the last year I don't
swim and I'm unable to perform my my job
so I have to find a new new profession
well what happened your buzz oh I had a
herniated disc your I wasn't worth or
well I heard of at home and then I was
working and they kind of got worse from
work and then had the first surgery to
fix it 100% I'll go back to work and
within two weeks three injured myself on
the job man
how old are you so we so went to court
or didn't go to court got a lawyer
settled and my wife is working full-time
so I'm like mr. mom over the past year
and a half or so so we haven't a pretty
good amount in savings
now Scott war I actually stopped saying
how old are you yeah I'll be 45 this
year what did you used to do installed
security systems and what do you how
much settlement did you get close to
$40,000 yeah and your mother your wife
makes what she makes about 54 a year and
you guys have been draining down the
savings during this year and a half
no no no Don her getting I was getting
workers workers comp okay and she
actually does a side job and when does
workers comp run out how it's gone it's
out okay so what is your new career
gonna be right now I'm looking for
something in the customer service field
okay how did you choose that just
something that's him not going to be so
physical demanding on my body right and
I have years of customers
like 20 years oh okay that's over 20
years of a lot of things that wouldn't
be tough on your body that aren't
customer service but if you've got a
background in that then you could move
into that field okay good okay so what
what's your plan then so well my my plan
is obviously to get a job you know ASAP
but before all this happened I went out
and I got it I got a truck now I have I
have twenty five twenty five thousand
dollars on the truck I have no other
vehicle my wife just has her vehicle
mm-hmm do I pay the truck off and just
be done with it if you don't get a job
making forty thousand in the next month
you sell the truck and get a different
vehicle because your truck's way too
expensive for this situation it's absurd
and I don't want you using a settlement
made a powerful truck you really can't
afford anyway if the settlement money
hadn't come along you'd be screwed on
this truck and if you don't get a job
now if you get a job in your household
income is ninety and you're twenty five
thousand our truck then yeah I'll pay
off the truck reduce your settlement
money by that much and work your baby
steps but let's get you in a position in
your career first so that we can say
this truck doesn't look stupid anymore
because you didn't know it when you
bought it what was always going to
happen I understand that but where
you're sitting today with a forty six
thousand dollar income and mister mom
has a twenty five thousand our truck
doesn't work right that doesn't work but
we're not going forward with that plan
anyway so let's you know let's not panic
and dump the truck today but no I
wouldn't pay it off today because you
may be selling it but I would get a job
as soon as possible I like give yourself
30 days go to Ken Coleman dot-com start
listening to Ken's podcast on careers
and I'm gonna send you a copy of his
book next week when it comes out on the
13th it comes out in seven days and it's
called the proximity principle and also
at his website are downloadable PDFs on
the interview process and on the resume
process and you need to download both of
those and read them they're not very
long and they're very very informative
when you're in the heat of a job hunt
but you need to you need to identify
some places that you want to go
work and you need to get in the business
are going to work there you've been
through awful painful stuff back pain is
one of the worst things out there I'm so
sorry you're facing that but you're 45
years old you got 50 years to do
something so let's get about the
business of doing that something you got
kids to feed and a truck to decide
whether we're keeping or not so you
might as well take a bow that chapters
closed that act of the play is closed or
come back out and do act 2 and that's
where you are and act 2 is everything
that happens to you wonderfully after
back surgery and that's what's under
your agenda you got it man you can do
this